good morning Millennials that help you
with that
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the Millennial morning show the morning
by the [ __ ] toast season cue season
she IRA me he got renewed thank God the
network was happy with our work in our
ratings this those big weeks at KNN oh
really yeah um good morning oh my gosh
it really feels like it's been so long
to be back here and when I woke up this
morning like I was very unhappy like
just to be alive and to be awake but now
that I'm here in full glam - my hair I'm
feeling very excited like there's so
much to talk about there's so much work
to be done and it's 2019 2018 was truly
the year of justice and we ended on a
very just note and I haven't figured out
what 2019 is gonna be the year but
whatever it is I'm sure merriam-webster
will follow in our footsteps and make
the word of the year again yeah and I
think 29 2018 was the year of growth it
was the year of learning and it was the
a lesson that I learned was at the start
of 2018 all we were doing was counting
our chickens before they hatch so I
think in 2019 we will be a little bit
more prudent when discussing the what
2019 will bring you know I don't really
understand what prudent means but I just
know it's the right word for this
situation
so 2019 is the year of prudence okay
sure so sorry about my voice but I when
I was a sexy Jew it Jackie she doesn't
even know what she's doing
no but I'm I endorsed it okay I was
talking last night by the time I went to
sleep I had no voice at all and I was
really worried that I was gonna have
nothing to give it to us today what
would have happened if I didn't have any
voice I would have shown up in like mind
through the show but you would have
literally had to talk I know I was going
to say it wouldn't be much different
than an average episode I just would
have an easier time cutting you off
totally there's nothing worse than today
you're gonna work me to the bone there's
nothing worse than just feeling so
powerless without a voice like
especially someone who like prides
himself on being the loudest person in
the room like not having a voice it's
like such a difficult time for me which
is why I like I can only do karaoke like
so frequently because that's always when
I lose my voice that's like the
beginning of that and when I'm drinking
and like screaming - all - well you know
I totally understand
it's very sad maybe I'll try singing
later you guys can loosen me up we have
such an action packed show for you
obviously we're gonna recap just in
personal adventures
no updates no that was Mary word um I
thought you were gonna say some personal
advances yeah but like then I thought
that was the wrong word
updates with some personal life updates
so much happened in the time that we
were off and in not only in our world
but then in the world around us so much
celebrity news the world didn't stop
turning unfortunately so we're gonna
recap the Fast Five that happened while
we are offline but before that let's
just dive right in I have a list of
things that you and I need to discuss on
a personal level on a personal level and
I wrote it down and now every time we
take a break we come back and say it
like it feels like we never left but it
really does feel like we left oh yeah no
I don't remember any of this no I'm kind
of nervous look at me
spooky spooby stuff it's the ghost the
speech isn't the first thing that
everyone is just dying to know about and
the same like I just can't stop talking
about as Olivia's wedding yeah I mean to
be honest like I had I mean I just have
like PTSD from weddings because mine was
such a treacherous experience even
though like looking back on it like
there was nothing treacherous about it
like everyone really got along there was
no like family drama like I was just a
nut job and I drove myself crazy but
like I had such a bad time at my wedding
and I don't have positive memories when
I think back on it like I love my
marriage hated my wedding and you know
what I think that's what's more
important me too but I feel like it's
whenever any child goes first at
anything there are lessons to be learned
and I feel like the bit of advice that
you never got that you needed which I
feel like now everyone tells everyone is
enjoy it take a moment you know don't
work people told me that if I get laid
back on myself and get myself one advice
would be being a shorter drink no I
watch Olivia like she do do dice you
guys that is the key to success is jumpy
engage flung and it's so funny when I
stuck whatever remembers societe made
you feel like a year engagement is
standard a year engagement is is long
anything you you can do to shorten that
you should do when I if we can give you
anybody when I first got engaged my
friend Elise his mom was like do it
that's just get it over with I'm like no
it's sad
oh boy was she right like I see Olivia
Olivia went through like one or two
weeks of just like busy treacherous
nests of
a big organized organizing everything
like that was it and then she got
married and now she could just like live
her life like I'm so jealous of that
like I had stretched out the treachery
for like six months like that is what I
learned and she was just such a happy
bride and I was like that opposite I was
a misery and I was like a an influence
my misery on anyone else I was a self
allowing in self pitying
misery miserable bride so I see Olivia
who's like literally glowing lame is
bright yeah Olivia had like sunshine
beaming out of her eyes she just did it
right and people like were like is she
pregnant am i she's getting engaged so
fast
what cuz she got engaged in September
and she wants get married on New Year's
so what she should be engaged for 15
months or three three makes no sense all
my life I thought that being engaged was
the greatest time of your life I'm here
to tell you that's just not true it's
definitely better than the months before
you're engaged but never comes ask me
the way you're ready it's like and it's
like I hope that I don't know because
it's to be a surprise like that's
annoying too sure it's also better than
the months of like not having a board
okay right but like being engaged it's
like great like the first week or two
and then it's everyone's like when's
your date but then it also like
everyone's like but you're getting ready
getting married so soon is like can
everyone come to hell down more people
ask me what my colors are oh my god why
is that a question I don't know and I
feel like people feel the need when
talking to a future bride to ask
questions about the wedding and I feel
like toasters and really my friends like
I went to a dinner with my friends a
holiday dinner with my Colgate friends
and it's like a lot of friend that I
hadn't seen in a while and not one
person asked me about my wedding and I
was just blessed so grateful blessed my
friend honor
they must watch the jokes my friend Anna
is obsessed with weddings like when I
was getting married every time we got
together she was the first person to
bring it up and I'm like oh my I wanted
to kill her and then my friend Margo was
getting married I'm like so good it was
on someone else and honor was always the
first person now Ana's getting married
she knows what she's done she doesn't
bring it up that's so nice yeah but
she's Eddie Mary I'm going to Mexico two
times in the next in within a span of
two weeks Tarte au lait no you know it
was really the wedding of the year and
what's so great is that it happened over
the course of two years so it was the
wedding of 2018 and 29 29 teen it was
the best night of my life having a
wedding on New Year's was brilliant like
I thought of everything like when I was
I was really just truly a guest because
we weren't like involved in the planning
at all
I'm surprised when they wheeled out all
these um new years like glasses had to
make genius like I didn't even think of
that I might but thank you
the been like I was just living as a
pure guest a pure gas like an important
guest yeah like everyone was like
wishing me Mazel Tov two great and
excited to see me
I was fortnight in all over the place oh
my god the kids are doing Jackie legs
just discovered that this is the move
that the kids are doing and I discovered
it when I went to Ben's little cousin's
Bar Mitzvah and all the kids on the
dance floor we're doing the floss and
this and like so stop seen the floss and
like it never spoke to me and like just
something about for at ninety like it
looks so fun and it really does require
like a little beat of skill and and
coordination right and like oh my god I
was fortnight and she got a headache and
I I mean I literally I'm barely out of
the woods on my hangover like it was a
true 48 I working over no siphoning fort
knighting did not help but I'm telling
you like did you drink at the after
party I had one drink and then I was
like this will do nothing positive for
me I just couldn't stop drinking and
like I was ready for the hangover like
cuz I decided then to do a dry January
so I'm like this is my final meal and I
just went so hard and I was like in the
cab home rolling my eyes behind my head
I took two advil before bed and I woke
up completely fine I can't talk to you
and I was gonna do a dry January and I'm
ready to days sober but then I realized
this Saturday we have a good friend's
birthday and I was thinking I'm like
okay this is the one thing in January
that's holding me back I'll either just
drink for one night or just sit this one
out like I'll so go but then I realized
I this big trip to Mexico where it's
like all about drinking and it's just
January's not gonna work for me March
might work for me because I don't drink
like I can't drink again I'm I don't
know if I'll ever get over like this
hangover and it's just it's just so
unfair because like I wasn't any more
drunk than anyone else no it's so unfair
because like there's so much fun when
you're drunk to that like for me like
it's annoying that you know but it's
like the universe is telling me not you
know I know
I wonder what do this maybe you need to
switch alcohols would you ever just try
draining tequila no cuz then like I'll
like be drunk and hungover and like
smelly and he had the smell is a problem
laughs maybe gin so Ben has his pimple
on his lip Oh i-i've heard about
everyone's talking about it and it's
here because I heard that he saw dr. V
Chapman and even he couldn't help so we
were joking like that it's a herpe ha ha
ha and then last night I was like
talking to Mario because Mario gets cold
or she doesn't have herpes she just gets
cold sores from stress and then I'm like
oh I thought this whole time we were
joking but like been totally has a cold
sore I'm like I've been kissing him do
you think I might get one I don't know I
didn't see that swear the story what do
I know and then I was up all night
reading the difference between pimples
and cold sores and there's a strong
chance that it's a cold sir but there's
also a strong chance that it's just a
pimple cuz it's like right above his lip
hmm and he popped it but you could also
pop a cold sore like you're not supposed
to so I was just getting all the
information from dr. Margo she when it
comes to cold sores Margo was truly a
PhD she is yes she's an expert in the
field yeah but dr. Chapman didn't have a
take on it well so we're now thinking
that he was actually wanting to give it
to been like kidding me just like licks
trash up the street and then like elixir
faces like it's disgusting this story
gets worse and worse
I know worse than worse I know has feel
so amazing and I give him a bath
yesterday and I'm like all about giving
him like the most fragrant soap because
I can they think it was dirty like I
wouldn't know but if he smells it starts
to bother I mean like I left you some as
a pillow so I came off like a smelly
pillow and I used of body I got a cold
sore right pinkeye
we used of body watching he's smelling
so good and it really was like
moisturizing for his fur he's so soft
you felt him my son he's a precious
angel of a man you know he's really like
and now I've been home for a month
straight and I was I was really gone for
like six months like every week and Theo
like started to resent me and he loved
Ben and slept with Ben and loved Ben Ben
Ben's legs Ben and now that I've been
home for a month I dedicated my life to
Theo and it has paid off like now he
sleeps in my legs and to be honest I'm
hating it because he really annoys me
when I sleep oh my god I'll take him I
had such like what's it called
Oh joint chicken next week cuz I
children got Wednesday Thursday Friday
maybe I will maybe that'll be oh and
that's
Zach's bachelor party oh my god I should
really take him oh my god I really
should Wow okay I have to think about a
lot to think about but I really was
having filled with drawers like while I
was gone
yeah all I did was like look at pictures
of him and like just talk about him and
you don't think we're so crazy no like
oh my god I can't and
obviously the picture surface I'm sure
you guys saw a CEO as a Russian Jewish
grandmother fleeing fleeing his his
vagenis already in the night it's a very
sad tale deal got a bath by his girl Ali
who listens to the chose and she's just
the greatest shakes the best pictures of
him and she wrapped him up in a towel
like literally schmatta around his head
and he and he looks like depressed in
photo two so it's really like literally
a babushka he looks like a political
refugee like fleeing his country and
jacking like created this whole
narrative about him leaving his Russian
shtetl with his mother's borscht recipe
the only thing that he had on him and
fleeing to America I mean and it's so
sad because he was the number one
matchmaker in this country right then he
comes here he doesn't know enough people
to make matches but then he was an early
investor in the Russian Tea Room where
he made his fortune and was able to put
all the money into his medical practice
this is like a children's book we need
to retire when I was thinking of this
story I might like I think of this stuff
like I just I think of your eyes I feel
rise about Theo's origin story and a
million things the counselor in the
camper right and they really think like
I have such a crazy imagination that I
was thinking I should write children's
books
you really should but and then you just
have Susan Mayer illustrate them for you
great what about Carrie Bradshaw when
she cigarette having Cathy right so to
recap it was a wedding of the century
Olivia's gonna come on next week and do
a whole recap she's there honey they're
mini mooning this week in somewhere and
they're busy and but when they come back
down to earth we're gonna I was
exploiting Olivia's wedding for all the
likes like I was out of control like I
was being so Thursday and like I don't
care no so was i it all paid off her
wedding had such good flow which as
someone who's planning the wedding that
really and someone who is obsessed with
flow but it's really something that I'm
worried about like when you click the
hash tag what do you see
but no for me my flow is poppin should
we talk about my flow in the Dominican
and whenever you want to get off oh no I
did it sorry there's just some drum I'm
just um oh there's a snitch I start you
continue but like what even a snitch on
I don't know this is her public congrat
okay continue my flow in the Dominican
oh my god literally I was in Vegas while
you were there and the point sky was
like who takes Jackie's photos like did
she literally plan this trip for her and
say oh my god
exacting my photos I did such a great
job and he always takes my photos but
one it really helps like having lost
some weight like it's like you don't
need every single photo of yourself that
is so true no like it's really I just
sometimes every time I get dressed for
the most part not so much in New York I
need to be better about it
I ask someone to take a picture of me
you know maybe it's gonna work for
Instagram and usually like it ruins my
night like I'm and there was in yourself
worth right and it's just I can't bounce
back from it and I just had the opposite
effect all throughout the trip and it
just really made me feel so positively
it was great also speaking of Olivia's
wedding I didn't episode with her patron
episode before the wedding about all the
details pre-planning so if you are
interested patreon.com social morning
toast and then we will do a post wedding
episode picture and really got got
everyone through the the drought we did
a good nature and me and Margo did the
funniest episode in the airport
recapping biggest cuz like we were
piecing together our night cuz we had to
flee literally were Theo fleeing Vegas
for Olivia's wedding and we were piecing
together our night and I literally just
put the phone on him like we should be
recording this and it was so funny so if
you are if there's any month to sign up
for patreon it would be now because you
get all that and then you get like 20
episodes before that yeah now we're at
like 30 episodes patreon episodes total
and we have a lot more to come like I
have so much stuff on deck it's just a
matter of time and play if I ever like
finish my home I will be doing some sort
of tour but or we have Olivia's home
tour coming up we have a three identical
strangers expose with a deck and
obviously all the wedding stuff that you
could ever need okay now tell me about
the genican did you have a good time I
had a great time and when I met well I
had a spray tan and I met so many
toasters really losers who were on
vacation in the Dominican my casa de
Campo and then I met one poster who
lives there and she was so cool of
course the twisters are always so cool
but it was really like you know going
across international laughs right now
that's insane toasters is even more
exciting than obviously meeting toasters
in toaster watering holes so I just
wants a shot at all the toasters that I
met you guys like really we're so cute
so it's like everyone came up as her
picture was like so nice to normal about
it could've been happier I took a couple
pictures with some like really tall
skinny girls in my bathing suit and I
hope we never surface yes but I hope I'm
a points guy we saw the Lady gaga
opening night show it was [ __ ]
amazing I had some critical just I mean
I'm the patreon I said I give it an
eight
point seven out of ten I had a little a
couple issues with it including the
setlist and some of the like the Enigma
like theme it was like she was trying so
hard to make this theme work like like
it was her [ __ ] Bat Mitzvah I just
like kept referring back to enigma it
was so stupid
but she is the true a true performer her
body Jackie oh my god she looked amazing
and like she was being seen from every
angle she was wearing a leotard her
vagina like she had it covered she was
snatched to death I have to see it and I
have to be honest I couldn't listen to
Eureka watch I want to listen to hurry
how because I don't think it'll give
away too much about the show no one but
I couldn't really watch all of your
stories because like I have to go and
experience it for myself
oh yeah and at one point I was it was
literally when I am and I was about to
get on a flight and come meet you guys
the night before TBG said they had an
extra ticket someone dropped out and
Katie Maloney was in Vegas and she was
supposed to take it but she got sick so
I was literally like we were doing this
I was home I just gotten home that
evening and I was up it was like 1:00
a.m. and Chladni was like the I'm
actually hit ticket Cup and I like
literally started looking up flights or
a third I'm like packing and packing and
then I went to my closet to see what to
wear and I didn't I couldn't find
anything to wear so that was that was
already like putting me in a mindset of
not going which was stupid but anyways
in the end we decided not to go I'm glad
I didn't go I have a bit like I have so
much business in Vegas coming up yeah
that it's fine I know it's sometimes
just think the kids have to be kids like
yes I can for tonight with the best of
them but you know I'm 12 years old and
we were like rallying hard and yeah I
don't know if you would have been able
to do it please no one rallies like me
that's true that's true and actually no
one rallies like Margo she is insane
I don't know I saw the true snitch
Jackie I saw cinch get out of a kicked
out of a club and then not remember that
morning oh I heard everyone hurt and she
didn't know that was the thing it was
like the turntable heard round the world
no truly it was okay it was so well just
listen to the recap and then also I just
want to tell you that the morning after
Olivia's wedding my doorbell rang and I
open the door and it was Ben's tuxedo oh
my god how crazy is that I am like so
angry me and Ben oh did you know if I
cleaners this no it's like um it's like
an uber for dry-cleaning it's like that
it's like much more expensive but they
deliver and you can track it like it's
supposed to be more reliable Ben sent
his tuxedo for Olivia's wedding like two
weeks ago it's the tuxedo that he wore
and literally they were dodging his
phone calls it never came they said it
was lost I said it wasn't lost they were
really reaching out like so crazy they
were dodging our phone calls Ben was
like can you call flag cleaners from
your phone because I think they're not
answering me I called they picked up
like so crazy never heard anything still
charged bed I was putting this on my
story because I was so mad and so many
people were like literally they lost my
entire bag of laundry or they sent me
half my lunch I have someone else's ID
supply cleaners that's like why didn't
you go to your regular cleaner it's like
it's like an app so it makes it so
cupful they pick it up and they send it
to like they outsource to a local
whatever I thought it was easier
accountability there there's no it's
[ __ ] trash doesn't like letting me be
a warning thank God we got it back I
wasn't even upset like yes it's annoying
because it text me it'll cost a lot of
money but it's like the sentimental
value we had all those cute little
engraved things on Ben's tuxedo from our
wedding like that's what I was really
upset about but we got it back TJ TJ TJ
it's so funny how you called him cpg
like at like to his face she was safe
and then I was like it's probably how
people call you buns like buns buns 121
but they like don't to my face and we
were in Vegas but like his friends like
it's like friends for 10 years and they
like we're not understanding I was
calling him tbg like they call him Brian
and I'm like who the [ __ ] is Brian
that's so funny I want to cut I was like
trying to fit in calling him Brian like
I just felt so wrong yeah Brian JC okay
so anyway have any new toaster say you
don't get that joke if you don't you
have to go watch old episodes because I
can't go into it right now I'm like
armpits are sweating you know I can't
get into it right now and I need Olivia
here to come and lie about it anyways
without further ado are you ready for
the Fast Five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast yeah okay
first story I think the most exciting
story because our girl Kim and our man
Kanye hire a different surrogate for
their fourth child
they are expecting I wonder if they were
unhappy with the first circuit or it's
just like not healthy for her to have um
they said the couple couldn't use her
again because she had just given birth
to her own child because on her TMZ
reported today well she's fertile
no totally so I mean that's her and her
husband's third child together that's so
cute
but Kim and Kanye are expecting their
fourth child with a new surrogate and
I'm just so excited well if you're a
true toaster in the morning toasters
Facebook group
we knew this while ago they say
yeah that they already have a fourth in
August and now people are commenting on
the old post being like Oh [ __ ] you're
right
also NTC had a blind about it like cuz
there's so much hype that Kim and Kanye
are getting two boys he said don't
believe behind they're about to have
another kid and I thought and he was
also saying totally it was confusing but
then right before this like when Kanye
went on a crazy Twitter rant Kim
instagrammed a picture from her holiday
party with a very famous divorce lawyer
and everyone thought it was like oh and
I even was like whoo but no but like it
was their holiday party together and the
divorce like right
I can't the holiday party oh I mean I
just want to say Kim did an amazing job
I loved the Grinch theme I loved the
snow but when they were all like in
their shoes and gowns running through
that dirty snow that had like it turned
black it would look so disgusting and
like all the pictures you could see that
like whitewashed snow because it was
really gross but what's so crazy is like
North West like a girl who who's gonna
be Holland fornia like woke up on
Christmas morning with snow in her
backyard she's gonna be an [ __ ]
nightmare when she grows up like like
that is when I saw those stories of them
sledding in LA like that's so crazy
no it's so crazy and I just want to know
based on of what we saw who do you think
was the drunkest person at the party say
it on three okay one two three pyres
Hilton she was being so funny the way
she was dancing like she is no rhythm
but she was just like throwing herself
into the fun and I just like I love
their friendship I'm so happy that we
posting pictures today we're together in
Aspen and then also she's really good
friends with Sophia so I really I really
I'm happy for Sophia Virginia has
someone like they call each other big
sis lil sis me a little counselor Camp
Irvine and I'm glad that like Sophia has
someone to lean on some sure she gets
like so intimidated going to the holiday
party horse and I really thought like
when she did that whole thing of like I
thought the decor was beautiful meet you
the party looked incredible like
obviously John Legend you know made
about himself about whatever's with that
like like there are other people who
sing hello like honey things no totally
no I'm like there's so many famous
people there who could have performed
it's like I don't know J Lo's they're
totally like she works so hard like let
her let her say yeah sure said I love
that J Lo and Kim respect one another
like like Beyonce and they say that she
hates Kim like probably does like JLo
and Kim respect one another like Queens
respecting Queens and JLo respects the
hell out of Kris Jenner I mean only a
fool wouldn't
Kris Jenner promoted second-act I kind
of want to see second act I never wanted
to see a movie like oh no sorry well I
saw Mary Poppins and I was like just in
the theater leading a life of regret
that I didn't see second act because it
couldn't have been worse than Mary
Poppins and I got a lot of [ __ ] first
saying lin-manuel Miranda was bad and I
don't care and then I spoke to someone
who is a Broadway like he works
full-time in Broadway he's an aficionado
he has seen everything I Broadway
multiple times and I said did you see
Mary Poppins cuz I wanted to get a true
artists a theaters perspective he said
no I did it and I can because lin-manuel
I'm like oh my god thank you like I'm
not trying to take credit away from the
fact that Hamilton was an amazing feat
like it is the greatest most successful
show of our generation and Lynne
Manuel's part and in creating it is
nothing short of a masterpiece that
doesn't make you a movie star like
overnight and I just couldn't deal with
it he was taking away from Mary Poppins
and she was good but he was the star the
whole movie was him and I just I just
couldn't like it was so bad and so long
do you think that maybe a piece of you
like can't coerce men well because of
the drama of course and I just have to
say the amount of people knew toasters
who think that it's really lin-manuel is
so crazy it's a code name and like I
kind of feel bad because it's like
people associate with him like one day
someone's gonna ask him on the street
that's gonna be like who is that yeah no
totally it's not him you guys it's not
the real lin-manuel it's weird because
as someone who like loves movie musicals
and like greatest showmen and anything
movie musical adjacent I've never like
had a thing for Mary Poppins
so I'm not dying to see it and now that
you guys didn't like it I'm especially
not but what I heard what's so crazy is
that they didn't use any of the bosses
so I don't supercalifragilistic about so
ever but like I could [ __ ] with the
[Laughter]
supercalifragilistic is they do a lot of
the work for us like they'll DM like
heather mccanna be like oh um the tro so
then have the Rotex it's like okay I'll
come in the toast they really get
they're like our publicists mm-hm and
one of them d-end Lilly Moscovitz what's
her name Heather
another something the woman who played
Lilly Moscovitz it was like there's the
show the morning shows like the
Millennium morning show they love you
you should go on and what did she
respond thanks for the warning like
thanks for the heads like yeah I think
she was not interested in you guys and
now I have a pit no I know it was
[ __ ] terrible
and I'm sure someone is found no totally
but like if you wanna come on the show
sure but it seems like very cryptic you
know it's just she's not interested and
you know what that's okay not everyone's
a toaster oh sorry I'm my twenty
nineteen resolutions is to cut back on
the singing I heard your I heard your
cries and only saying when it's
absolutely necessary
okay me too but you know who's to say
when it's necessary and when it's not
who's to say and so just a little more
Kardashian update which is that Sophia
Ricci joins Scott and Kourtney on the
big family trip over New Year's Eve so
not only was she at they were spotted
together in Mexico like Scott in his the
Lord in his ladies then she was at
Christmas and then she went on the
family trip to Aspen for New Year's Eve
and so like she's really in it totally
and I'm so here for it I'm so here for
Scott and Sophia like I shipped them for
real know now that like everyone's on
board I'm on board as well like I wasn't
on board at first and I wasn't on board
at first but after a year of them being
together like that's legit
you know Ann Gibbons and on the ship
once we saw him on the show he seems
like really good and that she's like the
exact type of partner that he needs yes
and I'm just happy that everyone's the
bracer but it must be weird because like
for a while she was really good friends
with Kendall and Kylie and then they
obviously dropped her when she started
dating this is baby daddy and now it's
like is she supposed to forgive them for
giving up on her it was like when blac
Chyna and Kim used to be that family the
family drama where they don't always
align this very confusing cuz like
Kanye's beefing with Drake but then this
weekend Kendall and Kylie and Travis
went to Drake's party so it's like I
don't understand like where the
Alliance's aren't that's where they
confuse me because usually they're all
like they stand but like here's another
interesting factoid that I found
interesting you know Abigail Taylor
Jeff's best friend read and named a big
yeah she follows and she's like Taylor
and Ryan and I nothing in since we're
thinking is absolutely nice of course
and I didn't belt it leave me alone she
follows Kendall and Kylie on Instagram I
just thought that was interesting you
know I found that yes sir she's like
well first of all Kendall and Kylie like
they are
little bit removed from yes like it's
not like she follows Chloe because they
are half sister yes maybe it's like when
your friend follow someone for you so
that they can get the tea and report
back
no it's crazy like Taylor goes on the
her Instagram to like look at what the
Kardashians are up to oh maybe but like
she could also do that on any Instagram
their public why her fans would find no
yeah but she can be convinced uh you're
like her mom and her fans behind totally
people are saying that her and Joel when
are gonna get engaged soon I saw that
but I don't believe it I think where do
people come up with this I don't know
like how did they know it's like when
people make up stuff about the royal
family it's like you don't know them
yeah Bromley told chose cuz you have an
accent does not an expert make that's
all the Kardashian but they were they
were giving us the content while we were
on break like they were really making up
for the for the loss of the toast they
were and I just love watching Kim ski
it's so she's so good she's so she's
such a beautiful skier and those hips
like the way they just curved down the
mountain they all really are so good and
they like film while they ski and like
it's like walking for them which is so
crazy you know it's just truly like a
rich people s'more like people who know
but like it's a rich people sport but
it's like they're not the type of people
that I think of what I think of people
who know like their heavy bottom oh yeah
totally
originally it doesn't make a lot of
sense but it's it's extra cushioning you
know yeah and they're not at like Kim
the the Jenners are orthotic but like we
are not so it is like it is yeah not
what you would expect true it's an
interesting factoid that I find
interesting I understand next up
Coachella lineup is out ariana grande
childish gambino and tame empower are
headlining the double weekend affair so
I'm gonna go through the lineup okay and
name just people's names who I have
heard of okay how does that sound
Janelle Monae the 1975 TJ snake I think
he does those end-of-the-year recaps yes
he does
Diplo Kacey Musgraves whoa did you see
address elbows on there did you know
he's a DJ no I didn't know that LM a
Jaden Smith I'm assuming that some is
that Jaden was a name Jaden Smith like
Will Smith's son yes she didn't he's
saying
yeah did you know also that terrible
boxed water in the blue cartons is
Jayden Smith's company what yeah when I
was at the Edition they checked in the
game to me I'm like no I'm good and
they're like it's Jade Smith's water
Mike I still don't want us so he's a
purveyor of water he's an artist
he was on the song Justin Bieber yeah oh
right and that I should of the rap you
should have known he wasn't that was the
collab of the century honestly it was so
good yeah okay then so that's everyone I
know on the first one Friday on the
second day
Tame Impala I've heard of that Solange
Kid Cudi Weezer Beverly do the slow for
tonight that's where I wanna be
gimme gimme did you see the SNL sketch
about Weezer
yes I did when they're all fighting at
that Christmas dinner but is that like a
Weezer thing or they just happened to be
like I'm talking about something so
random no I think it's both like I think
there's like a hardcore Weezer like cult
I think there's like Weezer cotton you
know
dad it was like the way Javits Center
ever it was funny J Balvin Billy Eilish
Maggie Rogers I know it's all Wow Wiz
Khalifa Wow he's on the third line how
the mighty have fallen
Ozzy he sings that song about Theo
beautiful beautiful beautiful
[Laughter]
every time I see Co I play that song for
you Virgil he's a singer too no he's a
deejay Arizona which is this a group or
an artist that plays often on Lauren
Bushnell's stories and there are very
soothing sounds okay I think that's it
for day two day three ariana grande an
intern choice as she is the artist of
the year and can be targeted towards the
Coachella community a community a
Collette love him
Zedd dillon francis shiver cheese love
them true birches yeah i mean i'm
searches
obviously but like if you wanted to be
churches know chipper just it's like
they're asking everyone push a t know so
we know that kanye won't be there gucci
gang did you get good she gained good
you gang and that's it for the third
night for me honestly like I'm not going
and I never was like Ariane I was like I
was like oh maybe in the Kacey Musgraves
under well but Casey's so interesting
she's the only person I think to learn
in the history of the world who has
played stagecoach and Coachella and I'd
much rather see her at stage coats
because thos sounds like a better time
and like the Coachella clientele
community well not a pretty sure for the
arty I appreciate her for the artists
idea no they certainly will not
yeah I was never going to Coachella for
a minute here I was like oh if I were
going to Coachella I might have like not
the worst time ever because of Ariana &
Co but it's just not worth going for the
most treacherous weekend ever especially
let me have to go two weeks later for
stagecoach I just like I I have my
priorities in order
no totally and here's the thing any
festival at that particular location is
going to be extremely treacherous
between the weather the walking just
like all of it and I can put up with it
for the happiness that is country music
for the love and and all that but I
cannot put up with all that treacherous
this for two acts that I really like you
know like I'm not gonna fly six hours
stand in the desert heat just for ariana
grande when she's coming to New York and
Madison Square Garden and if I really
want to see her I'll see her them right
and then it's like if you're gonna go
tell you like have to go to the parties
man like you find yourself like trying
to get into like a bumble pop up oh oh
my god trash good I'm so I'm so set I'm
all good okay next up Taylor Swift
season reputation tour came out New
Year's Eve yay New Year's Eve day New
Year's Eve day here's E oh yeah okay but
it was the day oh yeah yeah yes I
believe you know December 31st yes
I mean quality on trans long thought you
know I do um and I'm seeing a lot of
commentary that people are upset and I
mean me as well there was no like
backstage like juicy no gays like it
could've been a live stream but at the
same time that's the mantra there will
be no explanation there will just be
reputation she doesn't want to talk
about it she does want to harp on it
this this era is over and to be honest
I'm ready for ts7 like I I'm I wasn't
the biggest reputation fan I'm the
biggest Taylor Swift fan but like in
terms of all of her chapters of her
music reputation is pretty low on the
list her me and I'm really excited to
move forward into something else but
that being said I never get Taylor Swift
content so I just got two hours of pure
Taylor Swift and that works for me that
works me was great like background music
I'll definitely put it on again I didn't
watch the whole thing from start to
finish because he like
you guys were being insane but I'm just
I'm glad you need something for the
fence
no yes she's something like me she might
even have to down the DirecTV now back
to our channel but here's the thing
the thing is usually they tell people
like how much money these deals are
worth there there hadn't said anything
I'm dying to know how much Netflix paid
because she's never what do you think
though
how much genetics played her for the
rights to her thing maybe like 20 mil
what am i god I was gonna say more like
100 well cuz like think about it they
drop money that you make on her tour
like 100 mil no way more it's like one
maybe 300 right so like this is no extra
work for her yeah that's true
also Netflix like Netflix has it no like
they just throw money at everything like
they gave Adam Sandler's three hundred
million dollars to do a couple movies
like I mean he's big but he's no child
you know yeah so it's like they have no
value they don't value appreciate the
value of a dollar you know know that
they throw money at everyone and like
and Ryan Murphy also has like a 500
million dollar deal like Sandra Bullock
bird box oh my god I didn't see it and I
just I'm like loving not understanding
these jokes and I don't really want to
see it no I understand the joke because
she's very blindfolded it's really funny
like who someone says this I'm enjoying
the means I don't watch horror movies
like I know and apparently was very Pitt
inducing and I'm done with black mirror
and I'm done with things that could be
pits like I find that she's like mirror
movie no I have enough pits in every day
makes you think and no by merit yeah
makes me thinking in Lisa night really
the peg it makes you think the pig does
make me think because where would you be
if if the Prime Minister was [ __ ] a
pig oh where would I be um I would be
watching
I would not be watching I'll be watching
I know that I wouldn't be watching and
it made me think what kind of my watcher
or am I not
are you back row her are you a show her
yeah and I'm not a watcher no um I'm
just some of things that give me Pitts
cuz I myself have so many organic pits
that I grow in my stomach in everyday
life that I don't need to seek it out
and entertainment via streaming service
and that's all say but in terms of the
reputation tour very grateful for it
I love having just more Taylor stuff to
stream but I'm ready to move on so she
did the Dallas show did she wind up
doing her performance of Mary no she did
include any guest
Foreman says and she knew enough that
she didn't have em any like in the last
one she had so many and she included a
bunch of them in 1989 but she'd include
a single one because there will be no
explanation there will just be
reputation savage savage next up just in
a little bit more Taylor Swift news
because she had her New Year's party
everyone dressed up and it shows that
her squad has changed the 29-year pop
star who previously galavant did around
town with the likes of Lena Dunham
Karlie Kloss Lena Gomez Hailee Steinfeld
Martha hunt and more host near Z party
with a quote childhood heroes theme but
the guests were different from the usual
crap I didn't realize I was a theme
longtime friends Abigail
Lucy air Gigi Hadid Blake Lively and
husband Ryan Reynolds all attended the
soiree but there were some newcomers
including Iris Apatow oh oh that's the
older one no7 leave me on cuz Maude is
the older one mom a 13 year olds at a
party and they were drinking did you see
that Jen of course stylist Ashley avid
noni and model
Leah McCarthy quote Mary Poppins Audrey
area ms Frizzles Cinderella Gwen mr.
toad a Braille Nancy Drew posh by Rizzo
Frida Kahlo Steve Irwin Dorothy pretty
why was she captured in a series of
photos from the party quote this new
year we decided to dress up as our
childhood heroes sending you all love
and hope going into 2019 ok I didn't
know who that how anyone was except for
obviously Arielle and I also didn't know
I didn't know what they were dressed as
oh and Mary Poppins and I didn't know
who was hit ya know Dorothy and there's
so many things are happening from this
photo which is so crazy
okay Nicole looks great people are now
saying that Gigi was ever that saying
meaning they must have broken up but
don't they break up like everyone all
the time so I think it's a view not with
your boyfriend on New Year's Eve like
you're not together but then it's like
if you are with your husband Ryan
Reynolds and he's going to this like
chick party with Iris Apatow who's
13-year I know that's weird too you just
can't win I wonder I often think about
if Ryan Reynolds ever feel stupid when
he's hanging out with like Taylor Swift
in her like girlfriends like Martha hunt
you know what I mean I don't think so he
looks stupid he he looks so stupid but
what is he giving but like why doesn't
like Blake have friends her own age you
know yeah I mean I love them let her I'm
right cuz she's the girl in the cage I
love that Blake appreciates and anyone
who like loves Taylor I love but I'm
just like so Carrie
about these friendships and like what
the dynamics are I'm like do they text
no but like the parties used to look
really cool that 4th of July party will
always be like the time I missed out on
like with all the pie but like and all
the Patriot ale about this party
I was very my FOMO level was very low
like it didn't look down we're at
Olivia's wedding and say truly like
Taylor Swift and it wasn't about and
like Olivia was time with you doing
either would you rather have been at
Taylor Swift's dress-up party or let me
or the wedding of two years I mean
obviously Taylor's reps but like really
just in terms as far as parties go and
I'm a party professional a purveyor of
parties it didn't look like a good one
no it didn't it did not know I can't
believe that little Apatow girl was
there can we just check that that was
her what was her name iris
are we sure she's the little one I think
you're right yeah the other one you're
right she is the younger one how old is
she age 16 I mean I guess that's not
that weird for Hollywood but like it's
still kind of weird you know it like
hours of his 29 29
mm-hmm mm-hmm well you would know I
actually I like 100% that I've hold on
yeah that seems little hot Taylor's 27
or th Blake is 31
she's double I was the same Taylor is 29
I was right and Blake is double iris is
age how old is Ryan Reynolds I don't
know he looks 75 like the party needs a
chaperone yeah of course of course it
had to be respond credulous supervision
and Andrea Swift was busy so so they
called it the next best thing
okay next story
Miley Cyrus and Liam Hemsworth when the
waves are flooding the shore and I can't
sign my way home anymore that's when I
hi look at you guys didn't want me to
sing this is much again that was so bad
like maybe you worst but only because
your your voice is gone I thought it was
better
no sometimes you really hit it like when
with Miley's notes
I mean Tibby try again no it's good it's
good it's good you guys know we're all
good look what I'm against you guys so
self-conscious this is what you didn't
even change to us um
Miley and Liam are married so precious
so happy so wonderful I'm I wasn't it
was so humble even so humble it was just
like in their home and it was like the
same exact wedding that her parents had
but she's never gonna mess with glam
gown right and she was like ripping the
jewel and being a cutie and I love her I
love him I want happiness for them both
I honestly thought they were already
married me too they're like Kylian and
Travis like it doesn't really matter
they're just husband and wife right it
does matter what the government's and
their mom and dad right no she looked so
happy they're really just like the
cutest couple and I love the Chris
Hemsworth of it all like him and his
wife like really throw down with the
Cyrus's and but then the Cyrus's throw
down for them to feel like they had to
Australia yeah so I'm there really like
our great set of in-laws and I just I
love a smiley I love this just annoying
they like people who have money to like
throw the most extravagant weddings are
always the people who like literally
have a $5 wedding yes and you have the
money spend it and it's like a speedy
and no money like are spending
outrageously on weddings right but Miley
is a different sort of egg she's very
like hidden big making Priyanka spare no
expense no of course not like literally
the country of India like paid for half
that wedding dollars totally totally you
know what someone said like so she was
Miss India and she was she was in the
circus yeah before she was an actress
and so was Olivia culpo I'll be seen
like he obviously has a thing for like
pageant girls
makes you think maybe we should try to
pageant what's your talent be obviously
of course me to you what would you sing
the Cline I think I would do it's all
coming back to me now by Celine Dion but
maybe I would sing and dance show that
I'm not just a one-trick pony okay
apparently um people are really upset
the fact that I'm not singing but I'm
staying strong ya know you're gonna
suffer they've been final story Andy
Cohen reveals he's having a baby boy
such a shock such a shock and I can't
believe that we haven't spoken about
this yet because it happened so let me
happen
day that we finished right because like
Andy just wanted to be about him and out
our interpretation on the matter but the
50 year old television personality
recently announced he's expecting his
first child via surrogacy and on Monday
he shared the gender of the baby during
CNN's live New Year's Eve show which was
so funny I watched a couple clips oh
yeah I heard great things I didn't watch
the clips because you know I can't watch
videos on my phone is that should you
get nauseous
especially when I'm hungover so if
there's any video that came out on New
Year's Eve I'm not watching it except
Chrissy Teigen getting hit in the face
Tina require any sound so and it was
more so much if so much I was able to
stomach that I'm so excited and happy
for Andy he announced it on the watch
what happens live come o G faithful
episode and obviously all the OGS for
likes they really didn't know and
actually the footage that they have of
just the camera of the housewives
finding out is so funny because did you
watch it
Tracy's reaction is like 30 minutes
delayed so funny
so funny I just thought people take like
their feet into their own hands you know
I mean like you want a baby make one
like it's 20 a 1900 mm said 18 we can do
whatever we want and it's so crazy
because the baby's gonna be born
actually soon cuz it like this has been
going on behind right how many months so
it's like we didn't even know he was
dealing with all of this like now it's
just I mean now he actually just got to
enjoy the good part what do you think
it's gonna be like as a dad like strict
I think he's gonna be like he's gonna
let his kids like drink in the house
no but smoke pot yes yeah for sure just
so it's so interesting I would imagine
how lucky that baby is like I'm so
jealous I mention having Andy Kona's dad
mmm just a dream because a dreamin and
like all the house I'd look at your
aunt's yeah he's probably he's gonna get
such good gifts like for his baby like
so many ermes be like oh my god totally
everyone's gonna get me gift because
like everybody just wants you on his
good side and like all of the people who
are like work for him technically like I
was I was like they're all rich yes it's
not like usual like subordinates in the
workplace right like give you like a
little rattle right it's like you feel
bad because like you pay them and you
know even like everyone's doing okay Oh
something you talk about Vanderpump
rules I know
it's the greatest show on television and
so much is happening offline I'm sorry
online right now and even though like
we're living six months ago on the show
the tweets are like are still are still
happening apparently James went on a
terrible Twitter rant last night and I
read some of the tweets being like Jax
get over the fact that your dad died
like crazy
then he apologized and then Jack's like
oh please Bravo told you to apologize we
all know oh my god and then there's a
fake Raquel Twitter right with this
picture of James in bed with a bunch of
men including Logan insinuating
something but that Twitter is completely
fake but like for a while everyone
thought it was real it doesn't matter
the picture is real right or so it seems
but that's the thing about James because
like in the episode it's almost like you
know maybe he deserves like one more
chance I personally didn't think so but
like the argument could be made and it's
like but then you see in real time that
he's an even bigger ass wipe and it's
like why doesn't he ever learn and
what's so annoying about this show is
like the the irony of it all like people
like James why wreck hell why you still
with James like what she can't say it's
like I want to stay on the show and I
haven't made myself enough of a star to
stay on without him so if I break up I'm
not on the show and then I have to go
back to pageant school right in Sonoma
County right and it's like she's like I
have a degree like congratulations
everyone does that they can make you
special
that's so terrible but she talks about a
degree like it's like like she literally
graduated from Harvard with the PhD
right please I have a degree too anyone
can like pay money to go to college and
graduate like it's just it's it doesn't
look you special right um also it's like
as much as James is the absolute worst
like hard-working at me he's making the
show he is so funny when he was talking
about Sheena like nothing I don't think
there's anything funnier than like
British people are people without
American with different accents
imitating hands when Lisa does it it's
so fun yeah when James did it Sheena the
girls we're not going to be your friend
if you don't put James in his place
sweet Wendy James gave his brother
$5,000 I was like so cute now he's gonna
cry and they're like they made sure to
show it to us so that like right before
I got fired right and I did feel like a
little bad but like not really because
they still make my can be like a good
brother like a good family member and a
horrible person you know just because
you just because you have five five
thousand dollars in to give it to you
brother doesn't mean you're still
tripping not terrible right like you can
be a good brother to like something you
don't have to be terrible all the time
James is like a loving being the villain
oh but then like every couple of weeks
he like hates it and like tries to
defend himself and then like says
terrible things about other people like
you're the worst I'm not the worst but
like he loves being the villain right
and he
that's why he's on the show so like he
has to play into it but then when it
really like comes to bite him in the ass
like he really I think he does really
feel bad but he'd rather be famous and
on the show than a good person of course
but like that kind of reaction crying
like cuz you got your DJ gig cancelled
like isn't realistic like let's let's be
real you have behaved less per episode
when you don't work for Lisa right no
but like the the see-you-next-tuesday
thing I think that that that is very
real and it's really successful right
and like he is a DJ like he goes but
like he does to go to other clubs and
stuff but like I think that really is
like his bread and butter so I do think
that actually effects in his career as
opposed to Jax having to beg for his job
back my total that's a bartender like
total it's like [ __ ] making the
manager of Tom Tom like I can't it's so
unfair
it's so unfair and Lisa is such a [ __ ]
Mitch anytime she's in her confessional
like no one's talking about Jax and she
finds a way to insult him no I love Jax
we're interviewing people we're looking
for experienced bartenders just Jax
Taylor might be applying and it's like
one know a good memory one no one's
talking about Jax and two he's actually
an extremely experienced bartender he's
been working for you for like 15 years
Jackie I can't believe how much like
verbatim you're remembering stuff from
an episode over a week ago no I know
because it's like there was just some
things I really felt that he talked
about well it since it is 2019 I do have
many a resolution to work on and one of
them is my brain and I'm taking many
steps to get there vitamins Skillshare
not only do I want to better my brand
but I'm taking like Photoshop and video
editing on Skillshare I'm also taking
like brain like math like I need help
like I don't like these lines that
you're repeating I don't remember them
that's so crazy
I know I'm so excited I'm a huge
supporter of this and it's a great
resolution
I know Skillshare is an online learning
community for creators with more than
25,000 classes in design business and
more you'll discover countless ways to
take to fuel your curiosity creativity
and career you can take classes in
social media marketing mobile
photography creative writing or even
illustration like I I need that I think
now is a great time for like anyone to
sign up for school chair you can join
the millions of students already
learning on Skillshare today with a
special offer just for our listeners you
can get two months of Skillshare
for free Skillshare is offering the
morning toast listeners two months of
unlimited access to over 25,000 classes
for free to sign up go to scale
I am / morning toast again that's
Skillshare calm / morning toast to start
your two months free now Skillshare calm
/ morning toast i don't maybe I'll see
you in class
oh my god you guys could be classmates
laughing Pierce it was so funny when I
was getting ready today it felt like the
first day of school like I broke out a
new bag I felt like I was like putting
on my pens and pencils in yeah no I
didn't feel that way I felt like really
tired like what I was what was I gonna
wear for the first day of school I came
up with this monster like it all works
but on the feet I look like an animal
but a little nice on the feet I'm on our
72 you have a hangover I don't have a
voice and I'm trying you're doing your
best and it's [ __ ] Thursday we'll
start fresh on Monday it really feels
like a Monday it's like we came back
because like you missed us I mean we
miss you but like I could have
definitely waited until Monday Jackie we
were so undeserving of school supplies
as eleven-year-old so we didn't even
know the joy like for us he was just
like reminding us that school was back
but like what an exciting time school
supply shopping was it was such an
exciting time I think I personally
understood it a little more than you
just because I've always been very
planner oriented you know binders and
pens and pencils and like I used to be
so obsessed with my hammer anything like
every year I would try a new font Jackie
has the most amazing hammer I didn't
like truly like a foot like a computer
every year and when I was like in sixth
seventh grade like it was even better
than it is now I would try a new font
every year like my standard font then
sometimes I would one year I put caps
over my A's then I stopped dotting my
eyes which by the way is like the best
thing of all time I really you know I
don't got my eyes but that's confusing
cuz like it kind of looks like an owl
it's shorter than and now it really
isn't so confusing and then it's like
you have all these random dots on the
page like my pages are so you're free
week if I showed you guys many notes you
would die and so then like pens and
pencils and it's like I always had
different color pens and so my notebooks
would be in different colors and but it
didn't mean anything you know look like
someone who's like really serious like a
Monica Geller vibe right but it's like
no I Justin serious about the way this
page looks I understand I can't leave
you don't tell your eyes that's the
weirdest thing I know and it's like if
someone who you think that's arising
conscious 30 right Berry on top of
things she's by that you guys campitos
tickets sold out I did a couple tickets
got refunded yesterday so there might be
like two or three left but there was a
waitlist so I don't know
spot ticket yeah she this girl brought
doesn't email she was like honestly I'd
bought me ticket I was so drunk like I
can't afford a place we find me and I
was like for sure girl I got you oh you
you can get a refund for your ticket up
until like a month before the event so
there's like three tickets left just
because some girls cancelled but for the
most part we're all set I'm so excited
we need to start getting planning I'm
like the itinerary the activities social
events calendar trips to the Cape mixers
right clam bakes clam bakes for sure
yeah
kosher clam that's so so what are your
other New Year's resolution really
working on my brain working on my show
yeah the dirty jeans just like they go
hand in hand of course and just
continuing to be the skinny [ __ ] that I
am what about you that's a great one
so really peaking backing off of last
year's learning to cook of course
learning to drive now that we're running
the country club please accept us my
play I think that will be pertinent to
the situation and then I definitely need
like a Wellness one you know like I
drink a lot of water I don't even drink
that my child colony more being a skinny
[ __ ] like wouldn't hurt mm-hmm I mean
you're so skinny these days you're fine
but like it's not just enough to be
skinny like you know just a skinny
that's almost hard I was gonna say that
might even be harder than getting like I
only know how to gain or lose weight
like I was watching the Today show this
morning cuz the points I was on and I
didn't realize I'd already missed a
segment but I stepped through the
segment about this couple who together
lost over 240 pounds and it was so funny
cuz like they did this whole thing about
them and then they brought them out for
like the big reveal and their after
picture she was wearing the same dress
as she was running the Taoiseach oh my
girl get any dress just gonna tote oh
that's like the best part yeah and you
have to go shopping totally
maybe we chose shopping just gonna you
get me so yourself in the holiday
presents or did you receive I got an
iPad from Ben which I'm loving now we're
two gals with iPads and I brought it on
my trips with me and like having it on
the plane is a true game changer I
didn't even open my computer have ever
led you astray
never planner planner iPad iPad I'm a
planner is true game changer
music to my ears yeah I'm dumb with
Google Calendar like and they're [ __ ]
up time's up and I don't even notice
even 30 minutes before I'm not gonna
remember I get a notification 30 minutes
of every single day before the shows and
it's one of the most annoying things
that is so and I would give me such a
piss like
to delete the whole thing like it's so
annoying damn that is what else must be
discussed we're back tomorrow just
another fun-filled show hopefully I have
a voice but if not I know a girl who can
carry the show on her back
- you ever done the show alone
no I did it one right and when you did
it one it was horrible and that's when
we learned that that's not an option
no yeah I was like oh I love it all the
attentions on me it was terrible and
when I did the show in 15 minutes Oh so
like when you had to excuse yourself a
few weeks ago like I did the show alone
for throw rice and it was like really
[ __ ] hard it's impossible so that's
not an option I'd rather do you know
shadow yeah right or like call you and
do a podcast right um okay I can't let
me just breezed right by that we're so
on time and we missed 11:11 you guys
with me tomorrow okay or tonight um okay
so we will see you guys tomorrow any
housekeeping we got going on now we're
back tomorrow recap recap the real news
whatever happens hopefully some good
[ __ ] hopefully I like fur God had a
function cuz like the show's over what
did we say at the end this has been the
Millennial morning show the morning
toast we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube and
we're also available on demand as
podcast in the podcast app on iTunes
Spotify stitcher Public Radio all the
places that's all we got for you thank
you so much it's been a pleasure hanging
out with you this morning
peace out
you